-Today, the Justice Department
released Attorney General
William Barr's
redacted version
of Special Counsel
Robert Mueller's final report.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, it's finally here.
We finally have
a redacted version of the thing
that everyone in Washington
has been anxiously awaiting
for almost two years,
and for two years,
the media
has been obsessively dissecting
every morsel of information
or speculation
about the investigation.
There was even the time Mueller
was spotted at the airport
at the same gate as Don Jr.,
and pundits speculated
about everything from his
clothes to where he was going.
-We're about
to have a wow moment.
Stand by.
We now have the photo.
This was taken by Politico.
This is Reagan airport
in Washington, D.C.
The man spotlighted
on the left side of your screen
just sitting there, hanging out,
this is Robert Mueller.
This is the special counsel
who is the one we've been saying
knows way more than we all do.
-You know, it's interesting.
So, having worked
for Bob Mueller,
I know that he has two ties,
a red one and a blue one.
-Are we really
getting into the ties?
-It looks as though --
I'd be curious
to see where he's headed.
Is he taking a little vacation,
which is probably much deserved,
or is he going
to hunt for more clues?
-They were speculating
over the ties he wears.
Blue tie means Trump's innocent,
red tie means he's guilty,
and no tie means Robert Mueller
is ready
for a night out on the town.
Also, he probably
wasn't going anywhere.
I bet Robert Mueller
goes to the airport
just because he likes
going through security.
[ Laughter ]
"All right,
you're all good, sir."
"Scan me again -- for safety."
And on top of that,
we've been living through months
of endless speculation
about when the investigation
would finally end.
In fact, the media specifically
kept speculating about
whether the investigation
was wrapping up or winding down.
-Do you see Mueller
wrapping this up
at any point in the near future?
-When you read the tea leaves,
this could mean that the probe
is actually winding down.
-That multifaceted investigation
may be wrapping up soon.
-That could very well signal
that the investigation
is, indeed, winding down.
-Does this mean Mueller's
getting close to wrapping up?
-The investigation
appears to be winding down.
-Maybe this thing
is wrapping up.
-This could be winding down.
-It may be close to wrapping up.
-Potentially, the investigation
is winding down.
-That right there is my favorite
House of Pain song.
♪ Wrap it up, wind it down,
jerk us around ♪
[ Laughter ]
They've been saying
the Mueller report
was about to come out forever.
In fact, true story --
when they found
those 20,000-year-old
cave paintings in France,
one of them just said,
"Is Mueller wrapping up?"
Now the report is finally here,
but before he even had any idea
what was in the report,
Trump spent weeks
declaring victory and setting
incredibly high expectations
for how the full report
would totally and completely
vindicate him of everything,
with one small caveat that comes
at the very, very end.
-It was a complete
and total exoneration.
The Mueller report was great.
It could not have been better.
The finding
was very, very strong --
no collusion, no obstruction,
no Russia, no nothing.
The result was great.
No obstruction, no collusion,
no anything.
Total exoneration.
Complete vindication.
Everybody waited
for the Mueller report,
but then it turns out
that there's no obstruction,
no collusion, no anything.
I won.
No collusion, no obstruction.
I have not read
the Mueller report.
I haven't seen
As far as I'm concerned,
I don't care
about the Mueller report.
-"The Mueller report is great.
It exonerates me.
I've never read it.
I don't care about it."
[ Laughter ]
You're like a terrible boyfriend
who keeps giving mixed messages.
"I love you, but I need space,
and I can't live without you,
but you're crowding me."
[ Laughter ]
In fact, Trump even said
he was being charitable to us
by not overreacting.
-It's a disgrace what happened.
And, again, it should never
happen to a president again.
You're just lucky I happen to be
the president.
Because a lot of other
presidents would have reacted
much differently than I reacted.
-That's kind of true.
I mean, it really only happened
to one other president,
and he quit.
[ Laughter ]
Now, before we get
into the report,
let's just review
what we already know.
For one thing,
Mueller has already produced
a staggering number
of indictments and convictions
of some of the President's
closest aides and advisers.
I mean, look at this --
this group has more criminals in
it than a Hollywood PTA meeting.
[ Laughter ]
Two, even before
we got the report today,
Trump was already
directly implicated
in a crime to break election law
during the 2016 campaign
by paying hush money
to cover up an affair.
Of course,
as you might remember,
prosecutors mysteriously
referred to him
as Individual #1
in the court filing
despite also telling us that
Individual #1
"began an ultimately
successful campaign
for President
of the United States."
And then, in a big,
dramatic reveal,
Trump's ex-lawyer,
Michael Cohen,
revealed to the world
who Individual #1 was.
-Last fall, I pled guilty
in federal court
to felonies for the benefit of,
at the direction of,
and in coordination with
Individual #1.
And for the record,
Individual #1
is President Donald J. Trump.
-Yeah, dude, we know.
[ Laughter ]
That was, like, the easiest
"Where's Waldo?" of all time.
[ Laughter ]
So, what we already knew
was damning,
and even Trump's inner circle
seemed to know the report
might be damning,
which might explain
why their handling of the report
was so weird.
First, Barr issued his infamous
letter summarizing the report.
Then, a week later,
he issued a second letter
saying the first letter
wasn't supposed to be a summary.
Then, Mueller's team
started leaking
and saying they weren't happy
with Barr's summary.
Then, we found out
they wrote their own summaries
that Barr didn't use.
Then we found out Barr briefed
the White House on the report.
Then we found out Barr let
Trump's attorneys
see the report.
I mean, Jesus, who else got
to see this thing before us?
"I don't know.
I, uh...
I feel like it really..."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I feel like
I come off as bad guy.
Where are my Sharpie?"
[ Laughter ]
Then, this morning, Barr held
a press conference on the report
where he spun
all the conclusions
before reporters or the public
actually had a chance
to read the report.
No one had read it.
Well, some people had read it,
as Barr explained.
-Earlier this week,
the President's personal counsel
requested and was given
the opportunity to read
a final version
of the redacted report
before it was publicly released.
-That means Rudy Giuliani
got to read the report
before the rest of us.
And from the looks of it,
he was trying to open his eyes
wide enough
to read all 400 pages at once.
"I don't like to flip.
Spread them all out."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, on the question of the
Trump campaign's ties to Russia,
the Mueller report says the
investigation also identified
numerous links between
the Russian government
and the Trump campaign.
But in his press conference,
Barr chose instead
to highlight a sentence
from his report
that he knew
would please his boss
and repeated it over and over.
-The Special Counsel's report
states that his
"investigation did not establish
that members
of the Trump campaign
conspired or coordinated
with the Russian government.
The Russian operatives
who perpetrated these schemes
did not have the cooperation
of President Trump
or the Trump campaign."
The Special Counsel found
no evidence that any American,
including anyone associated
with the Trump campaign,
conspired or coordinated
with the Russian government.
Again, the Special Counsel's
report did not find any evidence
that members
of the Trump campaign
or anyone associated
with the campaign,
conspired or coordinated
with the Russian government.
As he said from the beginning,
there was, in fact,
no collusion.
-My God, halfway through that
press conference,
I started expecting Barr
to rip off his mask
and reveal it was Trump
the whole time.
[ Laughter ]
The Mueller investigation
had questions
it was supposed to answer.
Now we have the report.
We can take our time
and go through and hopefully
get answers to those questions.
And on top of that,
the guy who wrote the report,
the guy who almost never
speaks publicly,
Robert Mueller himself,
might actually testify
in public before Congress.
-Jerry Nadler,
who is the chairman
of the House
Committee on the Judiciary,
has now formally requested that
the Honorable Robert Mueller,
the Special Counsel,
come and testify before Congress
no later than May 23rd.
-Wow, we might actually
hear from Robert Mueller.
He never speaks in public.
Honestly, I don't even know
what his voice sounds like.
For all I know, he could sound
like Bobcat Goldthwait,
or maybe his mouth moves
like a "South Park" character.
-You will respect my authoritah!
[ Laughter ]
-We don't know.
So once Barr was done
with his press conference,
Congress and reporters
finally started
to get their hands
on the report,
but the way they got the report
was as weird as everything else
about how Trump's team
handled the process.
-Good morning, everyone.
So, here's how this plays out.
First, Congress gets the report
delivered this morning on CD.
-Now, we have this interregnum
for 45 more minutes
before members of Congress
and, of course,
the members of the public
are allowed to see
the CD-ROM of this report.
-Any minute now,
we are expecting
a Justice Department official
to come and drop off a disk
of the redacted report to the
House Judiciary Committee.
We are expecting, Jake,
in a matter of moments
the disk to be dropped off.
-That's right --
a compact disk.
They got the Mueller report
the same way we all got Encarta.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, this is how
the government handles
one of the most anticipated
documents in recent history?
Was it a report or did they just
send Congress a mixtape?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
The fact is, reporters were
waiting for this disk to arrive.
Everyone was literally
sitting on
the Justice Department website
reloading the page
where the report
was supposed to be posted.
-It is up, is online.
You can go to www.justice.gov,
and I think it's
/storage/report.pdf.
-We're just waiting
to find out more.
I'm sure everyone is eagerly
hitting the refresh button
on the Department of Justice
website.
-Oh, good.
So the same way people see
if they got
their Coachella tickets.
[ Laughter ]
Also, can we hear that
website link again?
-You can go to www.justice.gov,
and I think it's
/storage/report.pdf.
-My God, that link constitutes
obstruction of justice.
[ Laughter ]
Just buy MuellerReport.gov
or something.
If you're gonna make it hard
to find, why not go all the way
and post it at
justice.gov/storage/report
/no/collusion/innocent
/witchhunt/dontlook
/stopclicking/whyareyouclicking
/messageboard/napster.biz?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Still, now we have
the actual report.
And suffice it to say,
it's a lot more damning
and nuanced and legally dense
than Barr made it sound.
For example,
on obstruction of justice,
there's that question of whether
Trump had corrupt intent.
Now, Republicans have been
chiding everyone else
for thinking
Mueller's appointment
would be the end
of Trump's presidency.
They've been mocking people
for saying, "Oh, my God.
This is the end
of his presidency.
He's [bleep]"
But apparently, one of
the people who thought that
was Donald Trump himself,
because according to the report,
when his then
Attorney General Jeff Sessions
told the president
that a Special Counsel
had been appointed,
the President slumped back
in his chair and said,
"Oh, my God. This is terrible.
This is the end
of my presidency.
I'm [bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
Ugh! The one time we wanted you
to be right, and you weren't!
No, while not surprising
to hear that even after all
of the new damning details
in the report,
the President,
who spent the last two weeks
calling it a total
and complete exoneration
despite not reading it,
called the 400-page final report
a total and complete exoneration
despite not reading it.
-When I talked to people inside
the Trump campaign,
Trump advisers,
earlier this morning,
they just feel like
this is a complete victory.
I talked to one Trump adviser
who said this is $40 million
clean bill of health
for the President.
-I'm sorry, but Donald Trump
has never in his life
gotten a clean bill of health.
I mean, for one thing,
this is his doctor.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, good news, man.
I did an X-ray.
Most of your bones
are still there."
[ Laughter ]
Second, the report
is full of damning evidence
about the President's
various attempts
to influence the investigation.
Mueller writes
that those attempts
were mostly unsuccessful
largely because the persons
who surrounded the President
declined to carry out orders.
In fact, we've gotten
so many more details
about the campaign's
ties to Russia.
Just take Trump's ex-campaign
chairman Paul Manafort
as one example.
Manafort communicated with the
Ukrainian political consultant
tied to Russian intelligence
named Konstantin Kilimnik.
Kilimnik proposed
a peace plan for Ukraine
that Manafort
has since acknowledged
was a backdoor means for Russia
to control Eastern Ukraine.
Kilimnik wrote
an e-mail to Manafort,
expressing the view which
Manafort later said he shared,
that the plan's success would
require U.S. support to succeed.
"All that is required
to start the process
is a very minor wink
from Donald Trump."
Of course, with Trump,
it's impossible to know
if he's winking or just trying
to read off a teleprompter.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, this is
what he looks like
when he's just trying to read
a prepared statement.
-10,000 known
or "suspested" gang members...
-"Suspected,"
as in "Robert Mueller suspested
that Trump obstrusted justice."
[ Laughter ]
Again, the report is detailed.
There's a lot to go through,
and it will take time
for journalists
and political systems
to process it.
But it's worth keeping in mind
that after Barr's first letter,
Republicans told us it was a
major political win for Trump.
Compare that to a CNN poll
that found many voters
felt very differently
about the Russia investigation.
-Robert Mueller's work is done,
and among the many
remaining questions,
how will it weigh on voters
in the 2020 election?
-So, look, this is a recent poll
we just asked.
We open-ended it, said, "Okay.
What's the most important issue
for your 2020 vote?" so voters
could say pretty much anything.
But look at this.
Look where
the Russia investigation...
0% said it was most important
to their vote in 2020.
Exactly zero, zero, zero
respondents said Russia.
-Wow. That guy
went full Willie Wonka.
"Zero! You get nothing!
Good day, sir!"
[ Laughter ]
So, Mueller laid out the facts,
and now it's up to Congress.
In fact, there are multiple
specific references to Congress
in this report, including
one line that is very direct.
-I just think this sentence
is enormously important.
-Read it again.
-"The conclusion that Congress
may apply the obstruction law
to the President's
corrupt exercise of the powers
of office
accords with our Constitutional
system of checks and balances
and the principle that no person
is above the law."
This is an invitation
to Congress to say,
"You can do it
using the impeachment power."
-So, now it's up to Congress
to do their job.
I don't know if they will,
but if they did,
the Trump presidency would be...
-Wrapping up.
-Winding down.
This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]